[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAWEL SIARKIEWICZ:
I'm Pawel, and I'm
super passionate about
all of these features
because I want to make sure
that they're as awesome as they
can be for you guys.
So before I get into
the presentation,
scalable deployments and
updates in Compute Engine,
I just want to get a
quick read of the room.
How many people here are kind
of new to Compute in general?
OK, it's about a quarter.
And how many people are using
Compute but maybe aren't
using managed infrastructure
yet, so managed instance
groups?
OK, that's about a third.
And then how many people are
kind of like managed instance
group experts and you
know them inside and out?
OK, maybe like 50%--
good, good.
It's a good mix.
So let's talk about setting
up infrastructure, serving
infrastructure.
And whether it's
managed or otherwise,
there's little point
in setting it up
if you don't get your
software deployed to it.
And then what you
find is as soon
as you get version
one out there,
there's probably a
version two and then
there's a version
three, four, so on.
In fact, some of our
clients deploy software
even multiple times a day.
But these kinds of
robust deployments
of software to infrastructure
that is hot and serving
are only possible if you
have the right tools.
So that's why today I want
to talk to you about how
you can put together a serving
infrastructure with the managed
infrastructure features and
get your software deployed
onto it nicely and smoothly.
And I built this
presentation both for people
who are kind of new to GCE
and those who are using GCE
but aren't using the
managed pieces yet.
And if you are a managed
instance group expert, then
hopefully you'll still
get some value out
of some of the new features
that we'll be showing off.
So let's start small.
If you want to build a
service from scratch,
you might start with
one server and you just
provision a virtual machine.
And you might have given it
some sort of a clever name.
And then to deploy, you just
log in and deploy your software.
And when there is an
update, it's not a problem.
You just log in
again and update it.
And then that's fine.
But even when you have maybe two
of the servers or three, five,
or 10, you can
probably still manage
because you can come
up with 10 clever names
and log into each one of them
and deploy your software.
And that's OK.
It's getting a little bit
painful, but you can manage.
But when you start getting
into hundreds, thousands,
or tens of thousands of
servers, this manual approach
really doesn't work anymore.
And that's when you might have
switched to some sort of a CICD
system where suddenly
your servers are
these nameless, mindless
drones and they get spun up
by other systems or by software.
And now you don't have to
worry about naming them
and they just get created.
And that's really good.
But, when one of them goes
down, you have to do something.
Someone has to log in-- and
maybe it is actually literally
you--
to now restart this
machine, recreate it.
You have to take an action.
Or if traffic dips, you
suddenly have all these servers
that are idle.
And if you had a bad
job and it finished,
maybe all of the
servers are idle.
And that's why a
managed instance group
is this agent that monitors
your servers for you
and takes action on your
behalf to do the right thing.
Now that's really vague.
So let's break it down.
Manage instance group
has four major features.
One, there is the autoscaler.
So that's the thing that people
typically start with for MIGs.
And the autoscaler can
create and destroy machines
for you based on load.
And you can define what
load means for you,
whether that's CPU utilization
or traffic or, with custom
metrics, something
completely different.
There's the autohealer which
will recreate instances that
become unhealthy and go down.
And again, you can
define what unhealthy
means for your service
with custom health checks.
There is now one of the new
features, the updater, which
is currently in alpha,
going to beta very shortly,
which will help you deploy
software to your managed
instance group in a controlled
manner in exactly the way
you kind of need it and
what works for your service.
And there is regional, which
will split your machines
across different zones to make
your service more available
or move you towards
high availability.
So that's the four pieces.
And the one thing to keep in
mind with the managed instance
group is that all of the
pieces are integrated
and they work well
together, which is great.
But more importantly,
they're also
modular, which means that if
you don't need autoscaling,
you actually don't
have to take it.
Managed instance groups
are more than just groups
of scaling machines.
If you have a static
work set, then you
can have a MIG that maybe just
uses autohealing and updates,
and it doesn't even
use autoscaling.
Or maybe you have a zonal split
with regional and updates,
but you don't need autohealing.
And we'll dig into some of
these features in detail
throughout the presentation.
So now let's talk
about software.
Or more specifically, let's talk
about the software lifecycle.
And for purposes of
this, let's break it
down to something super simple.
You write.
You build.
You test.
And you deploy.
And because it's a
cycle, you do this
over and over and over again.
So let's say you
built some software,
and you decided to package
it into a container,
because containers are
cool and stackable,
one of these containers.
And now you have
your container pack.
And now you're thinking, I
want to get it into the cloud.
Well it turns out there
are a lot of options
for how you actually can deploy
your container into the cloud.
On one end of the spectrum,
you can go bare metal
and you can provision
your own machine.
You can install Docker.
You can configure it.
You can install the container.
You can configure
networking and you basically
do all of this yourself,
and that works OK.
On the other end
of the scale, you
can go with the
Container Engine.
And you can ask us to revisit
provision a cluster for you.
We'll manage the
cluster for you.
You then just upload
your containers.
And that works OK as well.
In between the two there is
Kubernetes, where you basically
take care of your
own cluster and you
install Kubernetes on it.
And then Kubernetes
does the kind
of scheduling of the containers.
And now we're introducing
this other option
that is essentially
UI passthrough where
if all you need is to put
one container on each machine
and you want some
automation with that, well
we'll take care of
some of the details
so that you don't have to worry
about setting it up yourself.
So let me explain to
you what that means.
You still start by
building your container
and then uploading it to the
container repository as normal.
And then in the interface, when
you go to create a new machine,
there's a tick box which says
that I want this instance to be
containerized.
And then you just pass
a link to the container,
open up whatever ports you
need, give it to command line,
and we'll take care of the rest.
And what do we do
in the background is
we'll provision the machine,
Grab the image that has Docker
already preconfigured on it--
it's the Google official Docker
image, put the container on
it, run the command line,
set up the networking
the way you open it up.
And that's kind of it.
So for that really
straightforward case
where you just wrapped your
software into a container,
this could be an option.
So let's take a look at what
that looks like in practice
with the new interface.
So you start as
you normally would
with creating an instance.
And let's give it a clever
name so that we can potentially
log into it later on.
Put it into us-central.
And here's the new
passthrough where
you can say, OK,
well, now I want
you to load this container.
Go over to the container
repository, grab a link to it.
And because this is a
really simple front end,
let's open up port 80.
And now we have to tell
the container launcher
how to launch the container.
So it's a script
written in Python.
So let's launch Python
with front end hc.py.
And done.
And that's it.
You can see those containerized
with that little summary
at the top.
The machine is spinning up.
And soon as it gets
provisioned, what will happen
is in the background,
as I said, we'll
basically load the container
on and run the command
that you passed us.
OK, the machine has
spun up and ready to go.
And when you go into
the machine then,
you can see that
it's containerized.
In the details, there's
a link to the container
that was preloaded on it.
And if we go to the actual
IP address for the machine--
give it a second to refresh.
And there you go.
It's serving the super simple
front end, healthy true,
and deployment done.
So that worked really
well for that simple case
we talked about.
We have one machine,
and it's set up.
And it loaded the container
with basically just a little
passthrough, great.
Now if we have a
managed instance group,
we want to be able to
create multiple machines,
because that one machine
might not be enough.
So maybe you need two,
three, 10, 15 of them.
But before you can create the
group, what you need to do
is describe how to
create these machines.
So the MIG needs a recipe or
a template, which will explain
or which will allow it to
provision machines for you.
Because the whole
point is that now it's
the MIG that will be creating
the machines, not you manually.
And when the template
is set up, the MIG
can be creating the machines.
So now let's take a
look at setting up
a containerized
managed instance group.
So same thing we did
with the instances,
but now we're going to
go with a group of them.
So we start with
creating a template.
And of course the interface
for creating a template
is very similar to the interface
for creating an instance,
because it's basically
a description of how
to put together an instance.
So you can see the same check
box to grab your container.
And we'll grab the same
version, open up the port 80.
And run that same
Python front end script.
Allow the firewall passthrough
for HTTP, and create.
And of course, the difference
is that when you hit Create,
nothing actually get created
in terms of instances.
It's just the template that
was created, so the descriptor.
And from the template
now we can say,
OK, I want you now to
create multiple instances.
So create a group
of these for me.
And so this is a second flow
into how to create groups.
The other main flow is to
create a group from the Instance
Groups tab on the left side.
But you can also create a
group directly from a template.
So now we'll give
our group a name.
And we'll call it next
containerized instance group
one.
Leave the single zone and
choose same us-central.
The template is
already selected.
And now we're going to
go with 10 instances.
Hit Create, and
we're good to go.
So now the group itself
is being created.
And as soon as it
becomes a resource,
we can hook it up
to a load balancer.
Because now that we
have 10 machines,
obviously we want to
have a single IP that
can be accessed by the users.
And so we don't want to have
10 individual instances.
So the group is being created.
The instances are being created.
And now we can tap over to
Networking and Load Balancer,
and choose one of
the load balancers
that was created previously.
But it's empty as in,
there is no back end.
So right now that
little balancer
has no target to
send traffic to.
And we can now, from a dropdown,
select the new managed instance
we just created, next
containerized IG1.
Hit Update.
And networking
will get connected.
Just make sure that the
instances are created.
So you can check each individual
instance, whether it's serving.
And yes, yes it is.
If we go direct, I'm going to
go back to our load balanced IP.
And it takes a second or three
to connect through networking.
And there it is.
And there you go.
So now the traffic that
went to the load balance IP
got passed through to one of
the containerized instances.
And it all works just
like we kind of expected.
Great.
So that worked really
nicely for that setup.
We have one machine
that we scale up to 10.
We can connect it
to a load balancer.
Everything's good.
But now our service is
a little bit exposed
to potentially going down.
And there are typically
two things that
can bring your service down.
So one, there is that
concept of a zonal outage
where all of these instances
we put into that one
us-central c1, I think, zone.
And if that zone goes
down or has an outage
or has some networking problems,
then your whole service
is down.
And then two, which is
quite frankly more likely,
is your software might have
an issue or the machine
might start crashing and
your service will slowly
start experiencing machine
by machine outages.
And that's what
autohealing can help with.
So now that you're in this
managed instance group,
you can easily deal
with both cases.
So let's take a look at
the zonal problem first.
Instead of a regular MIG, you
can create regional managed
instance group.
The main difference is
that the regional MIG
will split your instances into
zones, proportionally, and make
sure that they're
always balanced
in terms of their
number of instances
as you're scaling up and down.
So you don't have
to worry about doing
that kind of balancing yourself
across the different zones.
You just pick a region
and we'll make sure
that you have the right
amount of instances per zone.
So if there's an outage,
you're protected.
But there's a bit
more detail to this.
So let's imagine this case.
You have three zones.
You have your 10 instances
and they're serving
and you're happy.
And then zone A goes down.
Well now those
three instances have
to be reallocated
to the other zones.
But if a zone
really did go down,
you might have a
lot of people trying
to do the very same thing, which
means that at the time when you
need it most, you might be
not getting any of instances
because of stockouts.
So that's why the best
practice we advise
is to actually overprovision
or create additional machines
that you don't strictly need to
serve the traffic you have now,
but that you can use
when there is an outage.
And the best practice is
to provision basically
50% more machines per zone.
Now why 50%?
If you have this case and
you've got your three zones,
and you have 10 machines
that are serving
and you have some extras,
if zone A goes out,
those three machines
have now somewhere
to failover into or
have the traffic be
served by other
machines, which is great.
But of course the machines
you overprovisioned in zone A
are now offline as well.
So that's why you
kind of have to have
more in the other zones.
So that works really well for
that kind of zonal outages.
And now you're more highly
available, which is great.
But for certain use cases,
even that might not be enough.
And you might start looking at
cross regional availability,
which is out of the
scope of this talk.
But there is a really good
talk that happened yesterday,
IO204, designing
reliable systems
with cloud
infrastructure, which goes
into great detail of kind
of global availability
and how to think about that.
So check it out if
you want to know more
about how to protect
yourself from outages.
OK, so that was the zonal part.
But I did mention that
it's more likely, actually,
there might be software
machine issues.
So let's look at autohealing
and health checks.
Now health check is really
just a simple method
of determining whether
your machine is healthy.
That's all it is,
which typically
means you ping it on some
path with a certain frequency.
And at some point you
determine that a machine
is not healthy or needs
to be healed or restarted
or something.
And both load balancer and the
autohealer use health checks.
Now there's an important
thing to keep in mind.
These services actually
have a very different use
for the health checks.
So while they are both health
checks, when a load balancer is
using a health check
and one of the machines
reports as offline, it'll
just stop sending traffic
to that machine.
So the health check the way the
load balancer thinks about it
is kind of like a busy signal.
The machine says, I can't
handle any traffic any more.
I'm not responding.
The load balancer
says, no problem.
I'll stop sending you traffic.
When the machine comes
back online and starts
passing its health
checks, the load balancer
will resume sending traffic.
So that health
check can be fairly
aggressive in
determining machines
to be unhealthy, because
the cost of going unhealthy
is just, hey, this one machine
temporary stops receiving
traffic and then can resume.
Autohealer is different.
When a machine goes unhealthy
and it's an autohealing health
check, the autohealer
will recreate
the machine, which is a much
more disruptive occurrence.
So it does mean that when
you're designing your system,
you want your
autohealer health checks
to be more conservative
so they only
trigger if the
machine truly is down
and you want to make sure
that it gets recreated
and basically healed.
So now let's put
it all together.
And let's create a
regional managed instance
group with autohealer and
load balancing and containers.
So we start with
the health checks.
So let's create two of them.
The first one will be
for the autohealer.
So we'll call it
next-simple-hc-ah.
And for our little app,
we do the health check
on /healthcheck, so
it's easy to remember.
And we'll leave these parameters
as they are basically.
So the check interval is three.
And we can change
the timeout to three.
And what that means is that the
health check will be triggered
every five seconds
and we'll wait
three seconds for a response.
But what we're changing
is the threshold
to be three as well,
which means that it
takes three fails for the
instance to become unhealthy.
And we're checking
every five seconds.
So it's a 15 second duration.
So it'll basically
check, wait five seconds,
and go OK, you're unhealthy.
But this other health check,
the load balancing one, the LB,
we use the same path.
So the key is that the
actual health check
point, like the ping, the
heart beat could be the same.
All we're playing with is the
how aggressive or conservative
it is.
So this one is a
bit more aggressive.
So it's every three seconds.
And here the error is
that the timeout is five.
So you can't ping
more frequently
than you're waiting for
a response, obviously.
So we're going to ping
every three seconds,
and we're going to just
wait for two responses.
Which means that
it'll take six seconds
to flag an instance as unhealthy
for load balancing, which
is basically less than half
of our autohealing case.
And that's what I meant,
is that the load balancer
can more quickly say,
hey, I'm not going
to send you any more traffic.
But the autohealer
will wait a little bit
longer before it clobbers that
machine and then recreates it.
So now we're creating
the instance group.
We'll call it
next-rmig-containerized-1.
And to make it containerized,
all you need to do
is toggle this little switch
called make it multi-zone.
Choose us-central.
Let's just keep it
in the same place.
But now you're selecting
a region, not a zone.
So it will use the three
zones in that region.
We'll select a template
called instance-template-v1.
And let's do 12 machines
because, I don't know,
12 divides into 3, so we can
have four machines nicely.
Hit Create, and there you go.
And that's all you needed.
So that regional managed
instance group resource
is getting created.
And then as soon
as it becomes live,
we can start connecting
and networking to it.
All right, click in.
And the one thing
you'll notice is
you have that list of
machines getting created,
but now you can see that they're
split across three zones.
So you've got the c,
f, and b in there.
Now we'll go over
to load balancing
just like we did before.
And edit the back end to
select the newly created
rmig-containerized-1 regional
manager instance group.
And that's kind of
all you have to do.
Just select it as a back end
because that's what it is.
And the difference
from last time
is now we're going
to select that health
check that we created.
So let's find it, next-simple-lb
for load balancing.
So we want to make sure that
we grab the right health check.
Hit Update.
And that's it.
And then just make sure that
the instances now got created.
And the one thing that we
didn't do previously, so let's
fix it now, we didn't actually
select the autohealer health
check.
So let's set up autohealing.
So all you have to do is
managed instanced group--
and you can do this at
create or afterwards-- you
select the health check.
And then you can also
select an initial delay.
So that's basically
the amount of time
that the autohealing
will wait before it
starts testing an instance
after the instance gets created.
So it lets your instance
boot up and become ready
before it starts getting
potentially clobbered.
So you don't got into
this cycle where it keeps
on autohealing and recreating.
So the instances are serving.
So now let's go to
Networking and check
that IP that's
been load balanced.
That's shared amongst
all of the 12 instances
for receiving traffic.
Hit Refresh, and there we go.
And we're serving.
So we're good.
We're up.
So we have that first part down.
Out of the cycle, we
did that cycle one.
So we wrote some code.
We built it into a container.
We tested it.
We deployed it.
We're serving.
We're happy.
We're good.
We're ready to go
home for the weekend.
And then it turns out, hey,
version two dropped in.
So now you have to update this.
What are your options?
Well in the past you
had basically two things
you could do, and both of
them were kind of manual.
So one of the options is to,
OK, let's do all of this again.
Let's create a regional
managed instance
group with version two.
And version one is serving.
And now we'll live
reconnect the load balancing
and hope for the best, and then
disconnect the old instance
group.
And so it's all kind
of you're operating
on these live instance
groups switching traffic.
The other option
is maybe you could
change the template
inside your first group
and then force a recreate
of all the machines.
But then what about
your availability?
As you're recreating
these machines,
you're not serving traffic.
So both of these options
were somewhat workable
but a little bit painful.
So that's why we
introduced the updater.
Instead of starting with exactly
the details of the updater,
let's just talk
about what it does.
So at the highest level, the
concept is really simple.
You have a version one in blue.
You want all version to green.
And you just want to
update your instance group
without having to
touch networking,
touch any other setups.
But you still want that control.
So let's start
simple and let's just
do a simple update from
version one to version two.
So we start with our
managed instance group.
And if we look in
the details, we
can see that we're
split across the three
zones, four machines each.
They're all in version
one, so everything's good.
And now we click this new
button called Rolling Update.
And we currently
have version one.
Select two.
That's our green build.
Don't touch anything else.
And hit Update.
And there you go.
The new version starts
getting rolled out.
Now you can see that actually
six machines are being touched,
because what's happening
is one machine per zone,
so three in total, are getting
destroyed, and three in total
are getting created.
So we're destroying
three old machines
and creating three new
machines, one per zone,
and we're rolling it out.
And in the details you can see
that now we're saying, hey,
I'm going to take your
template one, version one blue,
to zero instances, and your
version two up to 12 instances
because you're going from
blue to green, all of them.
Great, so that works nicely
for that simple update
where you have to go all
version one to all version two,
one machine at a
time, or one per zone.
But real life isn't that
simple because what you really
want to do is this.
If you have a
service that is live
and you want it to
be highly available
and you have a new version and
you probably tested it a lot
and you're pretty
confident with it,
you still don't want
to roll it out 100%
into your live production,
just plow it in there
and hope for the best.
You probably want to do some
sort of canary, dip your toes,
maybe roll out one machine in
one zone, see how it performs,
make sure that there's
nothing crazy going on,
and then go forward from there.
So let's do a simple canary
update with the system, where
we start in the same
place, all versions
ones, same rmig for per zone.
And let's go to Rolling Update.
And the difference is, we have
the 12 blue machines in version
one.
Let's add one in
the new release.
So we add a version two, and
we're saying one instance.
And you can see that the
system adjusted the count
to say, well, we're going to
have 11 in the old version
and one in the new version.
And then hit Update.
And that's it.
Whereas last time you saw six
machines were being updated
because we're going through
all of them, now it's just,
we're creating one and
we're destroying one,
so we're replacing it.
And in the details
you can see that we're
targeting towards 11 and one.
So the updater is going
to maintain that rollout
because that's
what you specified.
So that worked well
for the one machine.
And let's say you
deployed it and tested it
and it works well.
So now you want to say,
maybe let's test performance.
But in order to feel
good about performance,
you want to have
a larger rollout.
So let's reload a third, or
33%, into your instance group.
And you're starting with that
single machine rolled out,
which is in one of the zones.
And it's serving fine.
And when you go to Rolling
Updates, all you have to do
is say, OK, well instead
of one instance--
I'm going to think
about percentages,
because I want to have a third,
whatever the size of my group.
I'll put in 33 for a third.
And don't touch anything else.
And hit Update.
And so for that rollout, what
you can see now is the updater
will create the
missing machines.
So it leaves that one
you already updated.
And in the details you
can see that the target
size, what it's going to, is
a third in your new version.
So it's basically targeting
that 1/3 canary rollout.
And you can check
on this progress
and what the target size is.
When it finishes the update, you
can run your performance tests
and then either roll
forward or roll back.
So let's stay focused.
We're doing really well.
Let's keep going.
We were skipping over
these parameters.
And they're actually
that magic sauce
that makes these
updates configurable.
So everything we've been doing
so far was along the lines of,
I just want to get
these machines out there
in a certain percentage.
But there's more to
this than you can do.
The first thing you
can do is instead
of rolling out your instances
like we were doing proactively
where, as soon as
you hit Update,
they start getting created,
you can be less disruptive.
You can say, I only
want to roll out
a new version when the
instance are getting
created for another reason.
Let's say your instance group
is scaling up or scaling down.
So that's opportunistic.
So you can say I'm only going
to update when the opportunity
presents itself.
The second parameter
is maximum surge.
Now this is all
about the concept of,
where is the update happening?
It's kind of the scratchpad.
So if you imagine you have
your serving set of machines,
and you need to take
them to a new version,
maximum surge allows you to
create a temporary scratchpad
on the side where you can put
up new machines without touching
these old ones, the
ones that are serving.
So you put up new
machines, and only
when they're serving and
confirmed as healthy you
take away the old ones.
So it's like a temporary
additional space.
Maximum unavailable is all
about this serving space.
And it's kind of your
disruption budget.
So what you can say
is, I want to update
inside my serving
space, but I only
want to update one machine at
a time or two or three or 50%.
And so the two
parameters together
allow you to roll your
updates out either affecting
your existing
serving space or not.
And then the final parameter
is maximum wait time,
which is all about
the rate of the update
or how much testing
you want to do.
So if you want to,
for example, not just
go one machine after the
other with a zero wait
time, which is what
we've been doing so far,
but you want to say I
want to, for example,
pause for 10 minutes between
each machines because I want
to have a really gradual one
machine at a time slow update,
then you would just put in,
let's say, 10 minutes here.
And after a machine updates
and passes its health checks,
the next one won't start
for that wait time.
So with all of
these together, you
can really configure the update
exactly how you want it to be.
And so for example one of the
opposite ways from safety,
because everything we did so
far was this idea of a really
slow and safe update.
What if you have a critical
fix or a fast rollback
and you want to update
as quickly as possible,
but you still don't want
to affect your serving set?
Then just set you
max surge to 100%,
and set your
unavailable to zero.
And then what the
updater will do
will spin up duplicate
machines in the new version,
make sure they're healthy, and
then destroy the old machines
only after these ones
pass the health checks.
So it'll do an update
basically in one step,
even if it is like dozens
or hundreds of machines.
And it's a way to
basically not have
to wait for that kind
of rolling update.
So with these
parameters altogether,
you can get different effects.
Can I switch to the
computer please?
So for the last
update, I'm just going
to show the actual
interface just
to show that it is working.
Let's say I want to
plow through version two
as quickly as possible.
And then we change the
instances to percent.
And so that will be all of
the instances that are going
to be surging, so additional.
No instances unavailable.
So I don't want to touch
my serving instances.
I don't want to wait.
Hit Update.
And what you can see is that
all of these new machines
in version two are spinning
up at the same time,
but the version ones
are not being touched.
And the other important thing is
if you tab over to the details,
you actually have 24
machines out of the 12.
So we doubled up our
capacity, which obviously
means that you have to
have the quota for it
and you incur the extra costs.
But it is temporary.
It's only for as long as
it takes for these machines
to spin up and pass
their health checks.
So it might be worth
it in certain cases.
And in terms of
the training, we're
going to none of these
and all of these.
OK, can I go back please?
One more concept with the
thinking about updates
that's going to be important.
So when we were talking
about the 1/3 rollout,
because the managed instance
group could have autoscaling,
you want that 1/3
to be maintained
as you're scaling up.
So that's an important
consideration where
an update isn't an action.
That's basically it you
set it and you're done.
An update is a
target, because if you
want to have a third
rollout, then you
want that third to be
maintained as you're scaling up
and you're scaling down.
So in this case, if three
instances are getting added,
two of them will
be in one version
and 1/3 will be in
the other version.
That was a lot of updating.
So let's think about
one more thing.
We talked about containers
as a packaging thing.
That's what we started
our little example with
and that's what we worked with.
And we talked about
templates and changing them.
And that's all good.
But if you're using, let's
say, startup scripts,
you don't need to
worry about templates.
So none of this applies.
And if you are using, let's
say, baked images and you
have an image family
where you just
want to be recreating
your machines
and not touching the template
and you pulling new images,
again, that's not what you want.
So there is also a
restart recreate command
where it's the same concept,
same parameters in terms
of control with max
unavailable, minimal wait time.
But you can just restart
or recreate machines
without touching templates.
So I started this whole
thing with the idea
of managed and integrated
features working together.
And now you might be
thinking, so OK good.
So you've got all
these automations
and they're all doing
their own thing.
How do they interact?
We touched a little bit upon
the autoscaling updating,
but there's more
detail than this.
What about, let's say,
autohealer and updater?
I talked about the disruption
budget for the updater.
And then there's the autohealer.
So what happens if
you launch an update,
and let's say you set your
destruction budget to five,
because you can
only afford to have
five machines down at a time.
And you set your max
unavailable to five.
And then the autohealer comes
in and kills three machines.
Well the updater
will know about this.
So it will only use
two machines while this
is happening, because it
understands that three are down
for some other reason.
When they get healed up
and come back online,
the updater will
pick them up and now
have its full budget
of five to work with.
So that works really nicely.
So you don't have to
mess with the autohealer
if you want to
roll out an update.
And you can still
have your budget.
But what about the autoscaler?
This is a little bit trickier.
If you have an autoscaler and
you set it to a certain target
threshold, and it figured out
that it needs five machines
to serve this traffic,
and then you say,
OK, I'm going to
roll out a new update
and I'm going to take
some machines down.
So two machines
disappear for update.
That traffic has
to go somewhere,
and it'll be served by the
remaining three machines.
But of course now they're
well over their target load.
And so you might
ask the question,
will the autoscaler
freak out and start
adding these machines?
Well no because the
autoscaler knows
that those two machines
are down for updates
and they're coming right back.
So as soon as they show up,
they'll pick up the traffic.
And the autoscaler doesn't
need to scale because it knows
that it actually wants five.
Now if in the middle
of the update actually
there was more traffic and
suddenly the autoscaler
thought, hey, I
need six machines,
then it would spin up
additional machines.
So it's not like it's paused.
It's just including
what's happening
in its overall calculations.
So that's the idea of it
being an integrated system.
And of course all
of the examples
I gave you were with the UI
because it's kind of more fun
to show.
But it's fully
supported by gcloud,
so you can write scripts and use
all these parameters in gcloud
as well.
So let's put it all together.
We talked about managed.
And now you can set up a
regional managed instance
group, which is resistant
to traffic changes
with autoscaling because you
can add and remove machines
based on whatever
load you specify
or however you think about load.
You can be resilient to machines
crashing with autohealing.
You can take new versions
and roll out updates.
And you can also be resistant
to zonal outages with regional.
So now I wanted to talk to
you or share with you how
one of our customers,
Descartes Labs,
used all of these
features together in two
of their specific use cases.
Now if you don't know
who Descartes is,
they're a machine
learning specialist.
And one of their big products
is crop yield predictions
and famine predictions
based on satellite imagery.
Now like all machine learning,
what they do this with
is, unsurprisingly,
a ton of computation.
And in fact they run
tens and thousands
of cores inside MIGs
all day every day
to create these models.
In practice that means
they actually ended up
creating a managed instance
group with a thousand machines.
And all of these machines
are pretty beefy to chunk
through the machine
learning models.
But the tricky thing is
when a new version shows up,
they don't care about
the old version at all
because there's no point
running the old code when
you want to have a new model.
So when they're rolling
out their update,
their disruption budget is 100%.
This isn't serving.
It's basically a batch job
that's just continuously
running on new batches of data.
So when you want to
roll out a new version,
you can do this all at once.
And when they run this,
basically all the machines
get updated essentially
in one step,
even though it's like
a thousand machines.
So it's a really
fast parallel update.
Now their other use case is a
little bit more traditional.
Once these models get
created, they actually
have to get served
to their customers.
And they do this through
custom front ends.
And these front ends
translate that data
in a way that's human readable.
And their customers
can use these.
Now they actually have
17 of these front ends.
Each one is a MIG and it's
autoscaled from one to 100.
And when a new version comes
out, all they need to do
is just actually
restart the machines,
because they use startup scripts
for their actual software.
But because they're
serving, they
can't take them down fully.
So in this case, based on--
in this case when they're
rolling out the new version,
all they need to do is restart
with a 10% disruption budget,
because based on
their use case, that's
not noticeable by customers.
But it's also fast enough to
go through all of the machines.
And because there
are 17 of these MIGs,
they can do a scripted rollout
with gcloud commands going one
at a time.
But because they're
nonblocking, all 17
gets submitted basically
at the same time.
And the MIGs update or
restart in parallel.
Now if you want to actually
know more about Descartes Labs
and how they set
up their systems,
there is a great
talk they did today,
IO235, how Descartes Labs
uses Postgres on GCP.
And they also talk a little
bit more about their setup.
So it's worth
checking out if you're
interested in that use case.
So there you have it.
We started with containers
and easy container deployments
on single machines or
directly into MIGs.
We looked at regional manager
instance groups, which
now can be split
into zones, have
autohealing,
autoscaling, updates.
And for updates, we looked
at the new updater features
which give you a lot of
flexibility and power
with how you version or
roll out new versions
of your software to your MIGs.
If you want to get started
or want to know more,
there's plenty of documentation.
And I think these
slides will be shared.
So if you didn't take
great notes, no worries.
And I just want to leave
you with this final thought,
to bring it all together.
Even if you want that kind of
direct control of instances
for your infrastructure,
you don't
have to do everything by hand.
Build the service by
choosing the managed
features that work for you.
And we'll help you out with
management of your service.
You're not on your own.
Thank you very much.
I think we've got some
time for questions as well.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]